- [Narrator] This is
Betty, a blue collar worker
who tends the counter at
a fast food restaurant.
And this is Wilma, she's
a white collar worker
who writes computer code.
Both make average salaries
for those two groups.
From 2010 to 2012, the salary
for Wilma's position would
have grown more than Betty's.
But from 2020 to 2022,
it was Betty that would
get the bigger bump.
Wage gains for some blue
collar workers have started
to outpace gains for white collar workers
over the last three years,
a reversal from a decades-long trend.
- This is a pretty
remarkable moment in history.
- [Narrator] Here's why wages
have been growing faster
for low-income workers,
and why those gains have
helped stave off a recession.
First, it's important to
understand who exactly qualifies
as blue and white collar.
- Blue collar has become a
more all-encompassing term
for lots of different wage
workers, often at the lower end
of the income spectrum,
but not exclusively.
And white collar tends to be
more salaried professionals
who are typically working
in office-like settings.
- [Narrator] Non-management
blue collar jobs tended
to include people that
work in restaurants,
hotels, factories, retail
stores, and construction.
White collar jobs include some,
but not all office workers,
like people in finance, tech, and law.
The pay gap between some industries
that fall in these groups
has steadily grown.
You can especially see that
divide between Betty and Wilma.
Part of the reason that
gap has grown in the past.
- There has just been so
much demand for skills
like computer engineering,
like software engineering
and not as much supply.
And there has been far more supply
of workers prepared to do low wage work.
- [Narrator] The pandemic also increased
the need for white collar jobs,
which could easily be worked from home.
But when the economy began recovering,
a different demand arose.
- To what hurt us the most is,
it's hard to find people to work.
- [Narrator] People returned
to activities far faster
than companies could
hire, creating competition
for many traditionally low wage positions.
And many blue collar workers
didn't return at all.
- We had a lot of retirees
during the pandemic who have not returned
to the labor market, and
immigration was depressed as well.
So we had fewer people
entering the country
to fill especially lower income jobs.
- [Narrator] Many workers
were also quitting
their current jobs, which could be a sign
of more worker leverage.
- When workers are
quitting in large numbers,
it's because they're easily able
to exchange their jobs for better jobs.
And when workers are being
laid off in large numbers,
it's because employers hold the upper hand
and are easily able to exchange
workers for better workers.
- [Narrator] Workers who did leave
for higher-paying jobs
also saw higher wage gains
than people who stayed.
- When employers are short-staffed,
the immediate problem at hand,
the fastest way to solve that
problem is to hire someone.
They're often prepared to
throw huge amounts of money
at hiring a new candidate,
signing bonuses,
you need a new benefit in
order to come on, okay, sure.
- [Narrator] So as demand
went up and supply went down
for blue collar workers,
the opposite happened
for white collar workers,
which kept their wage gains
at a lower level than
they typically would be.
- To the extent we have seen
shakiness in the labor market,
it has been in some of these
white collar professions
like the tech industry.
- [Narrator] While some
economists consider the slowdown
in white collar jobs more of a return
to pre pandemic levels, the
boost in blue collar pay
is keeping spending elevated,
even during inflation.
Hourly earnings surpassed inflation
for the first time in two years in July,
largely driven by gains
for low wage workers.
- We have actually seen some parts
of the economy receive real wage increases
that have expanded their purchasing power
and allowed them to buy more,
to move into better homes,
to invest in better schooling
for their kids, and to
improve their life conditions.
- [Narrator] Some economists say
that this increased spending
power for lower income workers
and the tight labor market
have been major factors
in avoiding a recession.
- So typically in recessions,
lower income workers,
by virtue of the jobs that they work in
or the tenure that they
have at those jobs,
tend to be some of the first to be let go,
or to not be hired in the first place.
If those workers are making more money
and they're remaining employed,
they are propelling
economic growth forward
and they are keeping
other people in their jobs
and they are preventing a
recession from happening,
which creates a virtuous
circle for everyone involved.
- [Narrator] While these earning boosts
have helped close the gap
between blue and white
collar workers somewhat,
the amount that Betty,
our food worker and Wilma,
our computer programmer make
today is still very different.
And as federal reserve officials continue
to tackle inflation,
they're taking an aim at
cooling the job market.
- What we're talking about is
having wage increases still
at a very strong level,
but at a level that's consistent
with 2% inflation over time.
- [Narrator] Wages have started to cool
and the trend has
reversed in recent months.
But some economists are optimistic
that the gains per low
income workers will continue.
- I don't think we're going
to see these wage gains erode
because the labor market is still tight
in those low wage industries
- But wage gains for blue
collar workers would need
to keep outpacing those for white collar
to continue closing the gap.
(quirky music)